you have some very uh had something very
exciting news break a couple of months
ago that you during the election yes
this was crazy you and your lovely wife
kristen bell expecting a baby and the
news broke at the
thank you
bro fertile yeah
i hope it broke oh my god could be
someone else's uh tell me what you hope
terrible terrible thing to say and
you'll always regret that
she's probably now currently shopping
for a new husband yeah
no she's not seeing us now we tape ahead
of time oh yeah um
the news broke dax yes the news broke on
cnn while the president was speaking
during the finale of the campaign yeah i
couldn't believe i think we have like
the last minute of his campaigning final
campaign and then look at the bottom at
the bottom that you see that little
banner yeah my theory is that at cnn
they decided you know to be truly
balanced we must have both a really
important news piece happening and then
a completely useless inane piece of news
happening simultaneously and then you'll
walk away going that was very fair
reporting yeah that was so you're there
to balance out yeah the re-election of
president obama that was the most
important thing happening in the country
coupled with the least important thing
and let me just tell you i never
imagined that i would my name would be
recognizable enough to put that banner
out there and when i thought about that
i thought i'd have a lot more money
you think that if you're that known it's
your favorite rich i'm basically like a
serial killer like famous and broke
you're upset
people know you but they don't have
nothing i got nothing okay i'm not
kidding i'm very wealthy uh doing very
well not really true yeah
great retirement fun
no no no no no no you have nothing uh
i've gone by his house it's on wheels
that's true you passed me is what's
happened yeah i've been in the slow lane
and you were
and i'm talking with your air horn and
your ferrari yeah yeah vintage ferrari
yeah
[Applause]
i don't know please does letterman have
a lot of cars
my letterman impression oh it's really
good it's really good
uh hey hi i'm david here's my thing
here's my question to you old chum and
this finger's gonna get closer as these
questions get better right
what do you hope that your child
inherits from you are you you know are
you are you thinking about that are you
thinking i hope my child inherits my
sense of humor my you know
well i really do hope that uh the child
looks identical to christendom because a
boy or a girl she's so beautiful yeah
i'm just praying or even a boy you even
want if you have a son i pray that the
son look just like my wife kristen
if we have one
uh the only thing i would like for the
child to have uh is my eyes because
they're unbelievable you have what do
you like about what do you like about
your eyes they're beautiful what's
beautiful about your eyes they're some
of the best eyes in the business
i would say before you punch in on these
yeah
hold it prepare it
is that lens is prepare us for what
we're to do flame resistance length
camera three yeah is the lens flame
resistant because i've broken lenses one
up
get in
[Applause]
there unbelievable huh yeah icicles i
it's been they've been described as
having icicles in them yeah
i mean what is that what is that
aquamarine okay
hey let's see if they can top these
peepers right here pal get in
what a creep
don't look like hey ladies it looks like
i'm peeking through your mailbox
[Applause]
man yeah but these guys get maced
regularly those are gorgeous i think i
think we both have really nice
on a previous episode of this television
show we both we discovered that i'm a
six and you're a five so does everyone
remember that no i don't remember that
you don't remember either you're a six
and i'm a i'm not a five your
personality is a twelve so you average
out to be like a nine but that's besides
the point my point is the worst guy ever
worst guy ever
has he won the war worst guy ever there
you go
oh my goodness
thank you so much what are you going to
do with that all i'm saying is that it
goes daniel craig it goes daniel craig
bradley cooper and then next shepherd
for prettiest eyes so
let's just hope the baby gets those
wait you're saying they've turned on me
i'm joking i don't think my eyes are
that good looking
it's just a joke no no it's not a joke
he really is that hung up on his eyes